I just heard that there won't be an anti
state flag demonstration and I think
it's wrong it's sick and it's disgusting
it's part of history it's a part of
heritage your heritage did not begin
with them so they would start if your
heritage too began when you brought my
ancestors away from a friend over into
the United States on both
[Music]
this resolution has been the result of
close collaboration between myself and
the leadership of the UM n-double-a-cp
on campus we felt that having a symbol
that promotes white supremacy on our
campus as we feel that the state fight
currently does is not promoting our
efforts to uplift inclusion by taking
down we're telling our students that we
care about you that we want to create a
safe from Tolerance back to fall
you
[Music]